(machine sounds)
(haunting chimes)
(computer beeps and clicks)
- Fireteam Osiris, over the last 72 hours
5 colonies have experienced
identical events-
massive destruction, Forerunner in origin.
A Doctor Catherine Elizabeth Halsey
has managed to contact us.
She claims to have
information on these attacks.
- Halsey is currently in Covenant custody
on the surface of Kamchada.
Your mission is to insert
behind enemy lines,
retrieve Halsey and bring
her back to Infinity.
Be advised, Dr. Halsey is accompanied
by Covenant Supreme Leader Jul 'Mdama.
If you have the opportunity-
- Understood Commander.
- Good luck, Spartan Locke.
Infinity out.
- Tracking gear online.
- Affirmative.
- Say, before we make this jump,
anybody want to say a few words?
- I figure if God can hear how scared I am
so can everyone else.
Locke, you buying first
drink when we're done?
- You ask, you buy.
(laughs)
- Fireteam Osiris, the light is green.
(buzzer and machine sounds)
(triumphant music)
(fanfare of trumpets)
- [Locke] Com check.
- [Tanaka] Coms working fine, boss.
- [Locke] Copy that, Tanaka.
- [Buck] Spartan Buck online and ready.
- [Vale] Spartan Vale online.
- [Locke] Weapons free.
- [Buck] Contact.
(gun shots)
(crashes and booms)
(gun shots and machine sounds)
(screams)
(gun shots and fighting sounds)
- [Vale] Heads up.
- [Locke] Let's bounce.
(gun shots)
(triumphant music)
(chime)
- [Voiceover] Get the Xbox
One Limited Edition Bundle.